what about the sphere in Vegas
we could talk about it you were just
there right
yes
yes two weeks ago or no actually just I
just flew in so I could go to the John
Muir Trail which is where I'm at right
now right so I saw this in person dude
it was [__] crazy
sorry I'm just laughing at some of the
comments from the bonus what are people
saying it's a rim job summer for sure
Remy
so this is a new like concert arena that
they that they've been building in Vegas
[Laughter]
people with headphones
that's a poop
Cody's ass just throws up
I love that
cut out that does your voice smell no
don't cut that out absolutely keep that
in
does it smell no
I mean that was like it was a sharp one
I'm a clean boy I mean it's just because
I'm sitting
what do you mean it's like I'm balled up
like a whoopee cushion what'd you eat
this morning nothing oh that's why
you're hungry yeah I see yeah I had a
little protein bar
so I should be the one ripping yeah well
once that coffee hits It's not well yeah
I guess the copper the protein actually
on the break you're it's not gonna be
you're gonna be yeah
yeah well we'll see anyways check this
out so it's a it's a sphere the whole
thing like when they were building it no
one knew what it was or at least I don't
know I didn't I didn't know just looked
like a sphere but the whole outside is
like
it's like LED screens so they can make
it look like anything
it's [__] insane there's videos of it
like as a giant eye blinking yeah
they should make it a giant nut sack
yeah
it's just a wrinkled testicle absolutely
should yeah
somehow they pump that smell of skin in
the air yeah
yeah you're walking yeah yeah it's like
that would be good but yeah it would be
funny if you walked in there like a
Vegas casino you know they always have
like their certain scent it smells like
Bo yeah it's just like gross
you ever um
you know I know you have I shouldn't say
you ever but
uh in Lisbon when I was like walking
around a ton
and I'd have my sit down Twitter piss
the Musk
what do you mean just because Lisbon you
gotta walk everywhere and it's like kind
of sorry oh so you're smelling yeah so
it's like undercarriages well no when
I'd sit down oh you smell it yourself
yeah yeah I see got you know I dropped
trial and I do a sit-down Twitter pass
yeah I do Twitter Twitter piece and I do
the and I do the you know the [__]
this
yeah and then I just get that [__]
that waft yeah yeah and you're like
yeah someone give me some baby powder or
something
Bond
yeah yeah this thing is is crazy all the
videos of it look insane they should
project the concert onto the outside of
the thing truly right just like the
artist performing yeah I know yeah isn't
that the plan though I thought they were
gonna do stuff like that that would be
so sick to entice but then wouldn't it
like encourage you not to go because you
can just get like any hotel room and see
that from the hotel room yeah but they
should make it a big boob yeah
shouldn't they like a big boob big old
nipple on the top yeah
wide areola and yeah yeah and you can go
in you go in and you can only get milk
from the concessions
these are these are these are big plays
right here I like this I like your
thinking
damn I just had a stupid ass style they
turned into a giant boob and it's just
like covered it in men like ants they're
just like latched onto it like they're
like rubbing it yeah and like no like
try their mouths yeah they're just like
stuff
like leeches
it's a boob it's a boob Circle
circulation
should do a show called like boob like
b-u-b with like a apostrophe over the U
or something
okay and it's all like boob related all
right super artsy yeah
right people are dressed up like like
boobs and the whole thing is a boob
and you can only order milk
okay
you don't think that's a good idea I
love it I want to be there right yes I
don't see that you're selling me I'm
enticed
like remember the bug one that we went
and saw or no you weren't you weren't
there right no no never mind
there was a bug one like they're all
dressed up like little bugs and they
don't speak English
that's the whole but the show is [__]
awesome it's still Cirque du Soleil I'd
be in there with my Bug Assault what
yeah yeah
my Bug Assault shooting performers
yeah this is the one right here we saw
this OVO OVO that's what I'm saying they
need a Boop
was Drake part of this
nice man imagine Drake doing the
headlining Act
that's how they talk
yeah I've been practicing that dude that
thing's holding the Bug Assault uh
[__] slug yeah there you go
see no
so what's this this was a great show by
the way did they say any words no they
which one
so you just watched yeah I mean it's the
same sort of like they have like
acrobats and but there's a little story
going on do you remember the story I'm
asked um
the bug the beetle guy
I forget what it was but it was kind of
beautiful honestly this is really
beautiful story they have like these
disgusting uh beetles in like a lower
income area yeah and then a cricket
comes along and he's like
coffee shop and then they're like
the bugs are like huh and then the all
the Crickets come and then they they uh
bring a bunch of leaves and [__] yeah
green leaves and then they they pay off
um the spider yeah it's about Hackney
yeah yeah and they just evict all the
bugs yeah and then the cricket comes
like
Whole Foods yeah
yeah and then they build a four plus one
apartment complex yeah
wow that's awesome yeah exactly just an
American story of love yeah
this is a play about real estate
that's cool dude when's the last time
you went to Cirque du Soleil never oh
you should go
it's [__] awesome
it's so fun
yeah I'm sure it's dope you should go to
boob yeah
like that cannot be the first Cirque du
Soleil
the the boob show comes out and I'm like
Alina we should go
[Laughter]
no we should really go
she's like you come on you're sick
you're like no it's supposedly it's art
it's amazing it's not even called boob
like these it's b-u-b and we get there
it's literally all titties and I'm like
my son
my son my song My Song is my song